OTIONAL, ILLE      INHEG
ON CAPITOL HIL FOCUSING ONTIM
AFGHANISTAIN 2021. MINS WOUNDED
COULD NOT GET THE AUITY TO
.
>> MY ROE
ep U CORPS  T ANDWSA  OF THE 35S
DAY.>>LAABILITY AND
NEGLIGENCE.
ONE SORDERED
THAYT BEEN ANSRE
R.
SHARED HIS STORYH THE HOUSE N A
THEYES THEOTIC A
BLOODY U.SRO
HO AAC
VAAS USED HIS SNIP
RIFL SA MAUS
SUICIDE BOT INTELLD WARNED WAS .
HE SHOWETHE MA TEAM R BATTCOMMAT
I ASKEHO
BE I
RESPONSIBILITY,  H, BUT  OUT. RN
LAAK
AND O INTERVIEW HIEXPERIENCE
>> PLAIN AND SE WERE
IGNORED.
OURTDIAR
NO ONE WAS HD UN
OUSAFETYorter: HE'S NOTH U.S. S.
HE IADEN
OUIC BSISTERS.WE ALL TRIED OUREA
>> Reporter: SOME WITNESSES TH
THE EVUA
>> GOOD AFTE Reporter: OTHERWI
>>A
BIDEN OR TRE
ER EFFEC
ITN ter: MULTIPLTNESSES OOD UP .
>> ME, US, PRIVATE
REIN FROM
GOVENTO SENTIALLY A GOVERNME NC
>> Reporter:F THE WHIDED TMO
A MENTAL HEALTH TSUNAMI FOR RA
AND HORDONWHENLENGING THAT WAS
WORKED WITH IN THE CRYET OUT SOE
TODAY WDI
OFFICIIMONY.MINISTRATION
BUT WE THA
MMBEEEKING
OUT THAT T
ADMIST OFFICIALS DJUN INIG
EGINNIABLY,
WAS PROVIDED ADDITIOHAT